[Music]
the council meeting for September began
with Mayor David Ayres acknowledging the
eighth anniversary of the Canterbury
2010 earthquake he paid tribute to the
resilience of the community and the
large amount of recovery work that has
been completed the council then looked
at speed limits on cones Road north of
cars Road a council staff report
recommended lowering the speed limit to
30 km/h and stalling additional signage
and undertaking maintenance work to
increase visibility in order to support
a proposed walking track at the far end
of cones Road however safety concerns
were raised by councilors over increased
use of the road by pedestrians after
extensive debate the motion was narrowly
defeated and the council resolved that
the walkway would not proceed at this
time councilors adopted the alcohol
Control bylaw 2018 the bylaw is largely
unchanged from the previous version
however the alcohol control area has
been extended to include Murphy Park and
Kaia Boyd during rugby and Rugby League
season the bylaw comes into effect from
the 1st of October
in following public consultation the
business zone one into public spaces
policy was also adopted this policy sets
out regulations for things such as
outdoor dining areas smoking outdoors
signage collecting for charity and
lighting the next monthly council
meeting will take place on Tuesday the
2nd of October
[Music]